hallo mein name ist nun meine lieben
zuschauer ihr seht es bereits im titel
eingeblendet wie reagieren heute alle
zusammen auf klassenfahrt dass ich habe
keine ahnung was das ist mir wurde
einfach unfassbar häufig in die
kommentare geschrieben ich soll hier
drauf man reagieren ich habe überhaupt
keine ahnung was das ist ich glaube das
ist sonne hilf mir 2.0
ich bin auf jeden fall gespannt auf dem
kanal wurden noch gar nicht so viele
videos hochgeladen
das heißt ich würde sagen wir reagieren
mal auf das hier folge 1
video läuft zwei stiche unterstützt
durch produktplatzierung
[Applaus]
dicaprio spielt von dem wir nicht wissen
jetzt gehts aber auch los hier wir sind
schon juden das mit dem global das ist
ein zeichen für diese hilf mir serien
[Musik]
ist das jonas rufe jonas und wels alles
klar die audi wie ich nehme gerade so
eine reaktion auf viele leute meinen
immer einen kommentar nicht sommer auf
klassenfahrt reagieren einem spielzimmer
mit das bist du noch oder bin ich blind
[Musik]
gerade der was passiert da gerade da
sind schüler oder sind es überhaupt
schüler auf jeden fall passiert gerade
eine klassenfahrt um die fahnen raus aus
berlin
wohin weiß man bisher noch nicht
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
also es ist anscheinend doch nicht oder
welches kette genau so stelle ich mir
auf jeden fall ein kennis vor
der bus ist aber immer mit der ruhe
[Musik]
ganz kurz posieren hingefahren
das sieht einfach echt scheiße aus fährt
man auf klasse hat nicht immer irgendwie
wandern in die berge oder irgendwie
skifahren oder an der nordsee
wir haben damals eine wattwanderung
gemacht da hat so einen typ einfach in
wohn gegessen
keine ahnung habt ihr noch lebt auf
jeden fall sind die hier allerdings
wirklich ja keine ahnung wurden gefahren
man nicht lass mal weg was ist gerade
der platten von dieser serie also man
sieht auch schon die bewertungen sind
jetzt nicht die allerbesten hast du
bitte aufhören
weißt du das nass wird das sind meine
sachen drin die erste woche
ich weiß was unglaublich war gerade hast
du sie mit recht der wo das also ich
verstehe wirklich bisher gar nichts
könnte genau jetzt im hilton seien in
moskau bei meinen eltern wo bin ich
drexler es so es war klar dass es wieder
so ein klischee abgedeckt wird
strom wasser und leitung
[Musik]
wenn die leitungen ist er von kabel
wurde ein handy frau homburger weiß was
ihr mann sind leitung für den
handyempfang ja hoffentlich gibts
überhaupt wählen kann
[Musik]
das sind halt diese witze die hat man in
der dritten klasse gebracht
mal schauen ob mich die serie noch
catchen wie hat ein paar sekunden später
was ist es dass er bitte für eine
scheiße aus der mannschaft war echt leid
die klasse und nimmt sich echt schlecht
wer wer ist frau ostermann was de cádiz
dieser junge hat sich also anscheinend
eine lehre hat auch noch mit dabei okay
die sind ja echt auf dem kompletten
bauernhof angekommen
was ist mit kenneth der post weder die
leute reden
ich bin klassenfahrt über kraft voran
meine freundin kennt hier bin
ok klassenfahrt ist schon eher für
singles und manchmal wünsche ich der der
jungen heißt sie glaube ich sie ist
zusammen mit dem kenneth also die sind
in einer beziehung und sie wer aber
lieber single ich habe letzte woche zwei
handys kaputt gemacht und da vor dem
hoffentlich acht oder sogar und jetzt
habe ich schon von renault steht mein
gott nein nein jetzt kaufen nicht
schlecht dass die kassen von biotop
stattfindet also
zum wertvollen agra biotop gleich eins
aufs maul nicht wundern wenn sie dich
schon längst betrogen hat
manchmal wünsche ich das warehouse
normal wenn jetzt direkt in der ersten
folge fremdgeht meine freundin soll auf
jemand anderen stehen und wenn man auf
zwei leute gleichzeitig steht dann ist
das bisexuell
in dem gehirn von canon das drin wie in
diesem gymnastikball nur luft noch einen
tag das ist super für die gedanken macht
durchschlafen kann also die serie ist
noch sehr vorausschau bahr ich kann euch
jetzt schon safe sagen dass er hier
wahrscheinlich auf dieser klassenfahrt
seine sexuelle orientierung finden wird
er wird wahrscheinlich mit dem hier
zusammenkommen ich hab gerade seinen
namen vergessen was auf jeden fall
passieren wird ist dass die freundin von
dem kenneth fremdgehen wird mit dem
stanley glaube ich und mit der
energiesparlampe kenneth geht's auch
direkt weiter rocken
[Musik]
du hast du hast du gemacht erzählen
ich habe mich nur nachts erkundigt weil
ich dich sind zur müsste schon
es ist nicht so hilf mir mäßig dass man
die leute sind echt krank am arsch wehrt
sich das denn überlegt sondern es ist
einfach so dass es zu dumm ist
man lacht nicht darüber dass man weil
man das lustig findet sondern ich habe
ein virus
er sieht ein bisschen aus wie aus seiner
japanischen zeichentrickserie meine
eigentlich ist mein es kann nicht dein
mädel sein wenn sie mit einem anderen in
einer beziehung ist ich hab schon
richtig richtig vielen frauen schlafen
ja aber auf einer klassenfahrt mit einem
mädchen die den freund hat das steht
schon das nächste er will dass so ein
bisschen als medaille haben quasi als
pokal
ich bin zur krassesten jetzt geklappt
hat
[Musik]
du gehst du gehst du also die giulia hat
jetzt sind nachricht von dem stanley
bekommen von wegen hey ich freue mich
auch heute nacht in therapie und die
julien hat dann richtig gut zurück
geschrieben
mama ich nehme gerade auf ich melde mich
später senden und das war es jetzt schon
das hat mir gerade geschrieben ja genau
ich spiele damit also ich putze jonas
produziert diese serie
ja super serie jonas an der stelle mich
das heutige video jetzt allerdings auch
beenden meine lieben freunde wenn euch
meine reaktion auf die erste folge kraft
klassenfahrt gefallen hat dann das gerne
einen daumen hoch bei diesem video ihr
da schreibt mir bitte und in die
kommentare auf ihr selbst diese serie
schaut zwar steht auch bitte dass alle
meine kommentare reaktionen et cetera
natürlich rein ironisch satirisch mit
humor zu verstehen sind
ich habe nichts gegen welche charaktere
ich habe nichts gegen jonas gegen
irgendjemanden aber die serie ist schon
ein bisschen quatsch
[Musik]